a fast-moving wildfire in southern
california has expanded to 10
000 acres in just a few hours with
little to no containment
the so-called lake fire roughly an hour
north of los angeles
has ignited force areas that have not
caught fire since 1968
some areas near the flames have been
evacuated officials say
people moving to nearby facilities will
have to stay in their cars
to follow social distancing guidelines
jamie yukis is near the fire scene in
lake hughes california jamie what are
you seeing there
good morning we've seen police and fire
crews lined up and down the roadways
here for miles because of hot spots like
this one
that grew exponentially in just a few
minutes officials are calling the lake
fire spread
extreme and officials here are calling
this fire uncharacteristically early in
the fire season
the striking flames from southern
california's lake fire burned so
intensely overnight
that at one point they spouted into a
fire tornado
it came hours after the fire began its
march across the hills of the angeles
national forest
fueled by gusty winds and extremely dry
heat
with temperatures in the mid 90s it
really created a recipe for
rapid fire growth early on the flames
exploded from 50 acres to 400 acres in
just a half an hour
plumes of smoke rose thousands of feet
in the air this is wild
wow more than 500 firefighters were
deployed to battle the blaze
on the ground and from the air as the
fire neared property in the area
officials said people in roughly 100
homes were asked to evacuate
and one fire battalion chief said up to
eight structures may have been damaged
by the flames so far
it didn't look good it was a wall of
flames
everything's burning up that was jamie
ukis reporting from lake hughes
california